مشاهدينا الكرام نشير الى طائفه من
الاخبار العاجله تريدنا تباعا وتظهر على
شاشتنا اذ تقول سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي انهم
اوقعوا عددا كبيرا من جنود العدو بين قتيل
وجريح خلال اشتباكات ضاريه في حي الشيخ
رضوان ويقول مراسل الجزيره ايضا ان هناك
رشقات صاروخيه مكثفه استهدفت تل ابيب
ويقول مراسل الجزيره في خبر عاجل اخر
ان ان دوي صفرات الانذار سمع في تلبيب وفي
اسدود قبل قليل اعود الى الياس كرام من
غلاف غزه الياس هذه
التطورات يبدو انها تحدث تباعا في الدقائق
الماضيه يبدو ان هناك رشقات صاروخيه كبيره
باتجاه تلبيب
الكبرى
بدون مبالغه محمود بامكان وصف ذلك بكلمه
واحده دفعه صاروخيه هائله هذا ما يمكن
مشاهدته حتى من المنطقه التي نقف فيها
الان كانت بالفعل دفعتين صاروخيتين
هائلتين من مناطق قطاع غزه باتجاه مناطق
عده في الساحل وكذلك كل المناطق الشرقيه
الواقعه بين اسدود وعسقلان وتل ابيب كلها
كانت تحت مرمى هذه الص ريخ بالفعل دفعه
صاروخيه هائله هذا ما يمكن توصيفه على نحو
لم نره حقيقه منذ اليوم الاول للحرب هذه
كانت دفعه صاروخيه كبيره جدا وواضح بانها
وصلت الى مناطقه بعيده جدا الى ما بعد بعد
تلي ابيب نحن نتحدث عن هرتسليا شمالا
ونتحدث عن منطقه كفار ساب هذه المناطق
الواقعه الى الشمال من مدينه تلي ابيب
يعني في حسابات
سريعه محمود نحن نتحدث على الاقل على مدى
يتراوح بين 90 الى 100 م من المواقع التي
اطلقت منها هذه الصواريخ باتجاه العمق
الاسرائيلي وهذا رغم ما تشاهده الان ربما
محمود من عدسه الكاميرا للزميل لبيب في
منطقه الشجاعيه رغم كل هذا القصف الجوي
والمدفعي الهائل الذي لا يتوقف منذ ساعات
الصباح والمقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت تملك
كل هذه قدره على توجيه هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه في العمق الاسرائيلي عندما اقول
هائله انا لا ابالغ هذه ربما كانت دفعتين
صاروخيتين من الاكثر شده منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب كان هدير الصواريخ وهو ينطلق من
المنطقه التي نقف عندها قويا وسريعا
ومتتاليه دفعات ورشقات صاروخيه كبيره
متتاليه في مديات مختلفه في اتجاهات
متعدده طال مناطقه واسعه جدا كل المنطقه
الساحليه من عسقلان حتى هرتسليا شمالا
كانت دوت فيها صافرات الانذار بالاضافه
الى كل الضواحي الجنوبيه والشماليه
والشرقيه لتلي ابيب وكل ما يعرف بالسهل
الداخلي يعني كل المناطق الواقعه الى
الشرق من مدينه الدود والمناطق الواقعه
حتى الى الشرق من مدينه تلي ابيب كانت تحت
هذه تحت حتى نستطيع ان نقف بدقه على على
حجم على حجم ما يحدث الان كم تبعد هرزل عن
قطاع غزه حيث انطلقت الصواريخ وكم تبعد تل
ابيب بالكيلومترات حتى نعرف بالضبط ما
يحدث الياس هز هي المنطقه الاكثر شمالا
التي دوت فيها صافره نعم تسمعوني اسمعك
الياس تفضل محمود هل
تسمعوني نعم قلت ان صافرات الانذار دوت في
مدينه كفار سبا وهي مدينه تقع الى الشمال
من مدينه تي لابيب بحساب سريع محمود على
الاقل اذا افترضنا بان هذه الصواريخ
انطلقت من منطقه ما في قطاع غزه فهي على
الاقل
اي بحسب حساباتي تصل الى 90 الى 100 م
هوائيا هذه الصواريخ على الاقل وصلت في
هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه الهائله التي يقدر
عدد الصواريخ فيها وهي كانت على دفعتين
باكثر من 20 صاروخا نحن ما زلنا ننتظر
بيانات ربما الشرطه الاسرائيليه والاسعاف
الاسرائيلي ليبلغ عن ربما ما خلفته هذه
الصواريخ لكن حقيقه عندما اقول هائله هذا
امر لا لا لا نبالغ فيه حقيقه وهو ياتي
رغم ما تشاهده يا محمود على الشاشه الان
من قصف مدفعي ومن قصف صاروخي بكل الاله
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الطيران الحربي دخل
على الخط المسيرات لا تفارق سماء قطاع غزه
المروحيات العسكريه لا تفارق اجواء هذه
المنطقه والمدفعيه لا تتوقف عن دك قطاع
غزه منذ ساعات الصباح ومنذ ايام ورغم ذلك
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت تبدي هذا
القدر الكبير على ضرب العمق الاسرائيلي في
هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه الهائله حقيقه والتي
وصلت الى ما بعد بعد تلي ابيب اي يعني
منطقه هرتسليا كانت تحت مرمى الصواريخ
كفار سبا كانت تحت مرمى الصواريخ منطقه
بيتح تكفا هذه المنطقه الواقعه الى الشرق
من مدينه تل ابي وانا اتحدث عن مدن كبرى
مع محمود وكذلك كل المناطق الشرقيه لسدود
وعسقلان ايضا كانت تحت مرمى هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه واسرائيل والناطق العسكري ما
زال يتحدث عن الانتصارات التي يحققها
الجيش ال الاسرائيلي وهذا طبعا يثير كثير
من الغضب والسخط في اوساط المحللين
والمراقبين العسكريين في اسرائيل الذين
يتساءلون عن اي اوهام يبيعها والناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
الذي يطوق الى سماع السماع عن الانتصارات
التي
يحققها الجيش الاسرائيلي ليغذي غريزه
الانتقام بحسب ما يقوله بعض المحللين
وكتاب الاعمده في الصحف الاسرائيليه
ويقولون بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول ان
يبحث عن صوره نصر له وعن تحقيق اهداف
وضعها المستوى السياسي للجيش الاسرائيلي
كانت منذ ال بدايه غير قابله للتحقيق كما
يقول ناحوم برنيع في مقال مهم له اليوم
وهو كبير المحللين السياسيين في صحيفه
يدعوت احرونوت ويتحدث عن ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يحاول ربما ان يعجل في عمليته
العسكريه وان لانه يعلم بانه سوف تنتهي
هذه العمليه قريبا في وقف لاطلاق النار
وان اخر عمليه عسكريه هي ستكون في في
مدينه تي خان يونس لانه بعدها سوف يسحب
الجيش الاسرائيلي جنود الاحتياط وسوف يوقف
هذه الحرب على الاقل في منتصف الشهر الاول
من العام الجديد دون ان ينجح في تحقيق
اهداف هذه الحرب بشكل كلي ذلك انه يقول
بان الاهداف لم تكن
واقعيه بقدر كبير
كما قال في هذا المقال اذا نحن امام مشهد
يذكرنا وكان اننا في الايام الاولى لهذه
ال الحرب المعارك على اشدها في كل محور
وفي كل مكان وفي كل زاويه في قطاع غزه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على
توجيه هذه الضربات الصاروخيه الى العمق
الاسرائيلي ما زالت قادره على الاشتباك مع
ال ما زالت قادره على الاشتباك ايضا مع
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من
مكان في
الشجاعيه وفي جباليا وفي بيت لاهيا وفي
بيت حنون وربما هنالك ايضا الان نشاهد
عمليه نقل لجرحى من الجنود الاسرائيليين
في منطقه غلاف غزه حيث هذه الطائره التي
تحط في مكان ما في الغلاف وتحاول ان تنقل
جرحى اسرائيليين من بين الجنود الذين
يصابوا بجروح بالغه الخطوره هذه الوحده
المختصه في نقل الجرحى من ميدان المعركه
المعروفه بوحده ست 6 69 وهي مسؤوله عن نقل
الجرحى من بين الجنود الاسرائيليين من ارض
المعركه اذا ارض المعركه مشتعل واسرائيل
واضح بانها بعيده كل البعد عن ليس فقط
توفير صوره نصر لا يوجد صوره نصر حتى الان
انما عن حسم هذه المعركه على ارض الواقع
الاشتباكات هنا في الشجاعيه وفي جباليا
نستطيع ان نسمع هذا ال هذه الاشتباكات حتى
الان وهي ال هذه المروحيه العسكريه هي
تغادر الموقع الذي حطت فيه قبل قليل في
مكان ما في غلاف غزه
وتنقل ربما جرحى من بين جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذين اصيبوا بالمعارك تنقلهم
الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه واقرب مستشفى
الينا هنا هو مستشفى سوروكا في بئر السبع
هذا المستشفى الذي استقبل العدد الاكبر من
الجنود الاسرائيليين الجرحى منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب هذه اذا طائره سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
المروحيه الاسرائيليه التابعه لوحده
الانقاذ 669 تنقلوا مزيدا من الجرحى
الاسرائيليين من منطقه الغلاف الى احدى
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه في الداخل بعد ان
بعد ان كنا شهدنا حقيقه في الساعات
الاخيره معارك ضاريه جدا في الشجاعيه وفي
جباليا وهذه اثار المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
التي تدك الاحياء الشرقيه والمناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه ورغم ذلك المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على ان توجه
ضربات صاروخيه قويه وكبيره ونحن نتحدث هنا
عن صواريخ لا تصل فقط الى منطقه غلاف غزه
كالتي كانت تضرب فيها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
صباح هذا اليوم المناطق الجنوبيه للغلاف
يعني ح ن نتحدث هنا عن عن نعم الياس حسب
فهمك دعني فقط اشير الى ما
تفضل نعم فقط اشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل
عندما كنت اقول بانها دفعه هائله تاكيدا
على ذلك من المصادر العبريه يتحدثون على
الاقل على 35 صاروخا ضربت على دفعتين
متتاليتين ونحن استطعنا ان نشاهد هذه
الدفعات الصاروخيه وهي تنطلق من فوق
رؤوسنا هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه كان هديرها
قويا واندفاعها هادرا قويا نحو المناطق
الوسطى و العمق الاسرائيلي وكان واضحا بان
دوي صافرات الانذار كان في كل حدب وصوب في
المنطقه الجنوبيه والوسطى حتى وصولا الى
الضواحي الشماليه ما بعد بعد تلي ابيب
نتحدث كما قلت محمود عن كفر سبا وهنالك اي
يعني عندما نقول كفر سبا نحن نتحدث على
الاقل على 90 الى 100 متر 100 م من
غزه ونحن والان هنالك ايضا الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن سقوط شضايا في مواقع
مختلفه
فيا لنتابع مع هذه الصور القادمه من تل
ابيب و تظهر فيها
بجلاء صفارات او دوي صفارات الانذار
واعتراضات القبه الحديديه لبعض الصواريخ
التي انطلقت من قطاع غزه واشرت اليها قبل
قليل l